It's just like, like, uh,
by publicly saying this,
you can speak to your respective group
and you have an immediate reward for it.
So it's like, you know, it's like, I
don't even know if we're more sensitive.
We're just more outspoken about,
you know,
things well because we have
an athletic more outraged.
They're looking to get outraged.
That's,
that's a really common thing now
that just didn't exist a few days.
I don't even think it's a, I don't even
think it's outrage, you know what I mean?
Like I really don't think it's outrageous.
Much as it cause outrage.
We've seen what outrage looks like at the,
when at the peak of,
uh,
like the black lives matter movement where
people at a course by people outrage.
Yeah. But that's in the streets. But
that's what I'm saying. But that's what,
that's what outrage is. And I don't
want to confuse that with like,
you know, recreational outrage. Right.
And it's really important to draw that
distinction. Right. And so it's like, it,
it's, again, people are vocal
about things, some issues, real,
a lot of things we started getting
upset about there. Like certain,
we get upset about certain cultural
appropriation things of the week because
it's a Sushi restaurant on
a college campus. Right. You
know what I mean? Like we,
we get caught up in those things but
[inaudible] and not focus on, you know,
like I dunno,
it's like real outrageous.
The thing that corporations
or afraid of isn't outrage.
It's trending.
You don't want to trend negatively for
like whatever period of time when when
people are upset with you and you've
done something genuinely wrong,
they'll show it beyond. It will extend
the scent that if it makes sense. Yeah.
Yeah. I think that a lot
of what outrageous is like
comedian trying out chokes.
You know, you try out jokes and 30%
of them are just straight bullshit
fucking work man. You try
him, they stumble out,
you gave it a shot or you'll ad Lib
something in the moment on stage and even
after you say like, what the
fuck did I just say? Yeah.
I think there's some of that
that people are trying to,
like I was reading this article the
other day about some woman who was saying
that yoga is supporting white supremacy
because it was the dumbest shit ever.
Some Indian lady,
she was seeing the cultural appropriation
of yoga by white people is supporting
white supremacy and you know,
it's really fun.
What are we doing exactly
what the fuck are we doing?
But that's what she did is she
tried a bad joke. You know she's a,
she works on,
she's a professor and some
bullshit college where
they're just just drowning in
liberal arts and she just figured out a
way to say something outrageous that she
thought made sense in
her own weird bubble.
But this got published in a newspaper
and then the whole world went just
collectively. What the fuck are you
talking about? But that's what it's like.
It's like you are,
I try and a bit late
night at the store you do,
you just just riff something and it just
goes into a corner and just get stuck.
Roomba vacuum cleaner things is bouncing
off the white like this is not working.
I got to bail out of this. Yeah, yeah. No,
it's funny because it is
like people people's age.
It's a creative force. She's
like, she tried to make
outrage where it didn't exist
and sometimes it catches
right like hoop earrings.
Like girls can't wear hoop
earrings anymore. Wait, wait.
Girls are scared to wear hooping hearings
because they're getting called out for
cultural appropriation by which
is hilarious by Latina chicks.
This is particularly Latino chicks are
saying and it's just all social justice
warrior bullshit. But what's really
funny is so I had, cause I'm an asshole,
I had to Google it. Well who the fuck
invented earrings? The Sumerians, the,
the oldest version of hoop
earrings is for 2,500 BC from Iraq.
So Iraqi's are the only ones who really
can claim cultural appropriation.
People wearing hoop earrings, not
Mexicans. So Mexicans settled down.
He does white girls alone cause you
stole a tail that was black girl. Shit.
Everybody Shit. It's like who invented
pants? Your culture appropriating.
You're wearing pants.
Who invented pants?
You were on a Korean phone bitching
about people doing, oh man,
talking about man. And it goes deep.
It's crazy. People are losing their mind.
They're looking for things to get outraged
that and so that they're trying jokes,
they're taking swings, you know, that
trying on pitches out there, you know,
you're spit balling. Well, I mean,
and eventually if it's like, if you,
you're gonna run out of ways to
approach it, you know what I mean?
Like you run out, we run a
places to, to stab the thing.
Well they try some that don't stick or
some stick for like a couple of days.
Like you remember Bossy, they were trying
to say, you can't say bossy. No. Why?
Why can't call girls bossy? It's sexist
crows, girls bossy. Don't call them bossy.
He was a thing where they were trying to
stop the use of the word or the phrase
bossy. They were saying bossy.
Sexist. Yeah. See, but like,
like can I ask a question? Where
did, uh, when, when did, uh,
when did cunt become a bad word?
It depends on who
you're in. England, man, they don't give
a fuck. Is that [inaudible] got hurt?
The herd used until like, I mean, nobody,
I didn't grow up around it.
I didn't hear people saying this.
I don't even think I heard it used
until like, I mean, I was probably theme
like a Hollywood bad word. Yeah, yeah.
No, it's word that when you used it,
you fucking really were angry. Yeah. Yeah.
It just, I don't know where it came from.
It's like the new bitch. It's not
new. I mean, it was around a long,
it's been around for,
so that was in high school,
but you called someone a cunt and high
school when you were a fighter brother.
Oh, shit would get deep. You couldn't
say con. You could say, bitch,
you're a fucking bitch. Fuck you. You're
a loser. You know, like you're a con. Oh,
dude. Well, there'd be like, what the
fuck did you just say? That's, yeah, I, I,
uh, yeah, I didn't hear it a lot at all.
And I could never imagine myself
casually called and some yet.
But if you lived in England, you could
oil, especially living in Australia,
they call someone a good con. Hey, he's
a good con. Oh, so it's a nice word.
Yeah. He's like, he's a, he's a,
he's a good dude. He's a good con.
Like people have, uh, my friend, uh,
Israel at a Sandhya style bender,
he wears a shirt that says good
con and he just wanders around.
It's from New Zealand because
they don't want people,
they think it's funny when people
get upset about it. He's a savage.
You better be careful.
Get upset with him. But
he's a UFC fighter. Oh, okay. All
right. Yeah, he's a, I mean, he's,
he's from another country.
It means a different thing in New Zealand.
If you say con in New Zealand,
it's a, it's like, I mean,
what's the equivalent? What would be
equivalent of con, the way they said,
good dude. He's a fuck good fucker.
He's a, he's a cool motherfucker.
He's a good con.
Where you asking because their style,
he wears that everywhere. No
one says shit. Yeah. Well, yeah,
but they sell those shares to look good.
I don't know.
Why would you ship Hashtag fuck
censorship Hashtag make co great again.
Well, I was going to say,
is it, is it that, uh,
what just like people's reaction to it
just kind of bothered me. Yeah. I'm like,
I'm like, oh, that's a,
it's a terrible battle.
Not a terrible bad word
like that where it sucks.
Like it ain't no motherfucker. You don't
like it. Don't think it's fun to say,
you know, rhythmically it's
just trash. Just like, bye.
I was going off of what we were
doing interesting shit. Trash.
I don't know if you went
to Australia though. They,
they would say it so many times it would
just slip in because this gets normal.
Yeah, I guess, yeah, it is just,
it's just one syllable. Like
it means dude over there sometimes like,
and this fucking con,
he goes over there and they'll,
they'll start talking about
it like this fucking dude.
They'll still literally say it in the
same way you would say this fucking guy.
Yeah.
It's just a different thing. I mean, look,
they're all just sounds that convey
expression, the world problems.
When you demonize one you say, you
know, you can't say the c word anymore.
Don't say the c word. Well, yeah,
I mean again, it's just like,
I just want us to have
like adult arguments. Yeah,
right. Well, it's hard to
have adult arguments, even
forbidden words. Well yeah,
we'll book has,
that's like the,
the shit that your sister got mad at you
about growing up. Right. He called me,
you know what I mean? Like is kind
of like, that's the thing. It's,
I mean you were saying intention earlier,
but I mean there's always
like intentionally, what
do you mean by I get an,
I get in like these types of my mom,
southern Christian women in any curse
word that I say any curse word is very,
she, she doesn't, she doesn't like
it. And I, I her on all the time,
I'll always do just because we get
into the argument while simultaneously
respecting, you know, her views and
beliefs. It's also like, you know,
these cuss words redid
your fucking kitchen lady.
I love her. I love watching
her like react to it. Like fun.
Yeah. Yeah. Because just like, oh
this through the filter of you,
like really, you know. See
I grew up non suppressed.
My parents were hippies and they didn't
give a shit where we said we just do,
we get, I couldn't really say
it at school, but you know,
there was no like language restrictions
in my house. I'm allowed to say anything.
That's great. Yeah, it
was weird. That was great.
And my friends would come over the house
and you just say fucking funny your mom.
I'm like, yeah, fuck it.
I used to you were I did you grow up
around people that like used to just talk
shit back to the mall and so
like it was never did that. No,
it was fun to why I had,
I had a friend,
my friend Alex is still one of
my favorite moments of life.
It was just like we came,
I came to this house after school and
his mom's name is Patricia and she was
just like, I'll take out the
garbage. It was like, go to hell pat.
His response, cause mom passed.
She caught it off. I like,
my mind was blown.
Told his mom to go to hell.
It was like amazing. And she just
argued back like it was. Yeah,
I was so mama was a dad
around. Uh, he knows that,
but it wasn't around like,
it was always so amazing. It was
amazing. That's a struggle that,
who's the man? When did you start
cussing around your mom? Um,
it's been a few hours. No,
I probably started, uh,
I mean I moved out when I was
a teenager, so I, I probably,
I mean she's heard me say it to kind
of throughout, but just in kind,
like not stopping it in conversation.
It's been years. I mean I just, Oh,
it's just kind of float. I'm low key,
still afraid to cousin from mine.
I cut it from my mom,
cuts in front of my niece and nephew.
How old are they? Well, all
of my knee, I have a, uh,
an 11 year old niece or nine year old
nephew, a couple of two year old twins,
a three year old niece,
like just,
and I am myself and speak exactly
how I normally speak around it.
You're an adult longer than you're a
kid, you know, and so it was just like,
why am I going to pretend the world
sounds different? Look, I, I'm with you.
But, and for like his kids are that
your brothers, your sisters? My brother,
my brother and sister in law.
Everybody cool with that or
they get upset? Uh, fake.
I mean they go like a come sometimes,
but it's also they get it.
They might my brother that they're very
understanding while they, they get it,
they get that. It's just like tell people
talk. It's how real world. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. I mean I think that's
important. Again, you don't want to,
that's the thing man.
Just like don't even know you fucked up.
If you're at a job where
you're not on keen, not swear,
but you can't swear off job with the
people you work with or does that help or
they'll get, yeah, you
can get trouble. Yeah. He,
if there's certain jobs where people have,
where they,
they got off work and they went out with
some coworkers and they told a dirty
joke or start talking shit like that
will get back to human resources and
there'll be fired.
Bosses are now following their
employees online and shit. Like Twitter.
That girl that got fired from NASA,
fucking hilarious.
She got fired from NASA yesterday. She
was like, Holy Fuck, I got a job at NASA.
And some guy tweeted her, he
said, language, and she said,
suck my dick and balls. I work
at NASA. And he said, yeah.
And I am,
you know,
one of the people that oversee something
at Nasa and then [inaudible] are not,
well, she was about to be an
intern working at NASA and
she was like, here it is.
Everyone shut the fuck up. I got
accepted for a NASA internship and look,
he writes language. She
says, suck my Dick and balls.
I'm working at NASA and he says that
I'm on the National Space Council that
oversees NASA.
Yeah.